hi guys we are super and this is why
it's kpop support we'll talk about the
first question let's go hashtag ask
super n can you describe the member next
to you with one word good one please
good one okay pennies lie cat Oh genius
mother character tale
I don't sometimes these remind me of
gingerbread man you know if I'm straight
hey did your breath okay gingerbread man
Oh God
trick trick anyway pass enemy that's it
good gingerbread man bye hung about just
do I'm curious who was the first group
that introduced you to kpop and do you
still stand in now during PE something
Mu Sigma is a cos bottom line and that's
again asthma the : ah Gregory who the
boy anymore
I wish name in so rain that's cool yeah
I told you such a kid shiny under around
emotional ending oh honey Julien oh me
oh my
so for me is boa and shiny and for me
shiny TX - um I'm gonna choose your
crayon you still see you again you know
touchy job now Canada a bit chilly it
money to Chris's now could be all do you
give and the next question is from Tater
Tot what's your favorite music video
doesn't have to be kpop oh that's hard I
was so into rose all her videos are very
like the colors and the concept were
very very interesting so I keep looking
through all her music video I love
Justin Timberlake such anti Oh certain
time featuring jay-z the temple monument
don't mind so much so that internet well
we're all fans of each other so yeah and
store a and you look good yeah start
what are the significance of lightsticks
and kpop I've always wanted to know I
don't know sometimes they use it in
conscious and divide it up when the
artist uses it to light up and in the
color they want I think or something
like that penlight - got a teammate
Chris excelent everyday so cool oh yeah
Timmy 27 version one day Oh kill me -
penguin - imitating machine gay the
manga you would hit her hands Radhika do
without Dave oh my I don't want to be
taught human labor conjugated our lights
take is pink pink and we chose pink
because we represent
early
s/m and SMS color is pink so we use that
as our nightstick as hard as hard with
an exclamation mark okay does anyone
find kpop music video is really
addictive like you come back and wanna
watch the same video more and more oh
thank you Madonna we meet Peter Bonnie
Bob
this is not nothing they could not have
done it tickles did you beautiful Wow
CAI says he's never seen his own music
video more than what the next question
is from Holly website what are the best
three kpop music videos that had come
out so far this year pick one I'll pick
only three yeah
chopping moonwalk want yeah for me NCT
dream mm ah Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom I know one
mine's like Timmy young famous famous
famous smoke without HT legit which
point one yeah so me it's like taming
famous tail lights NZ dream boom and
then Peck you're like set1 to seven
superior this one is from C Azana let's
go addicted to kpop dance practice
videos especially those with intense
routine complicated synchronized sharp
on point beautiful genius choreography
how do they do that
hashtag impress come talk to me oh yeah
easy videos in Hangul practice what will
I do Jake Raja Muda ninja cut cheese ham
Adam so two batches in hooked ending
what it doesn't matter go do then you
don't want to be is it Tim accrued
poison getting back that's 1 X 1 soft
Jen is dancing alone to k-pop songs in
your and your apartment
consider this workout I think I think so
you can you can still call it a workout
and as you know you're moving your body
it actually requires a lot of you know
more energy to dance so it depends on
how hard you go on the dances but for
sure kpop bands
pretty like in 10 so if you do it
correctly you can have a good body on
this day in kpop alright what's the kpop
lyric you always have stuff in your head
calm face and I like her that was a song
called dangerous women it hasn't been
released yet but if you come to the tour
you can listen to it oh yeah so the next
question from shave feel like am I too
old to get into kpop it's pretty fun no
I think cable is for all ages though
they you don't need to be young to love
kpop and say all over the place you can
every age can love kpop
to help us think cool AG let me show no
more to limit how she seemed uh you're
not too old
hang on you don't read this out for us
okay
Christian is print prior right Karim
paya of pure and player up here Empire
pure mmm I appear Empire
okay it's your empire okay what was your
motivation to be coming in either close
up when you I took a look at all will
get it on the other cookies charitable
cuddle and for me is you know step up to
I watched that movie and from then I
start to take dancing as my hobby and
then my grandmother really like in
fluent means hula becoming a kpop idol
because she keeps showing me Super
Junior and from then I started watching
Super Junior and then boy oh boy and
then shiny and that's makes me hear that
bring me here so this homemade oh I
don't take each on a tour or age no much
was all naked a I don't take it away
turns on can teenager tone energy poor
to are yeah I usually run Amiga
the teenager a human ingenuity
I mean Tunisia in Dorado or did he pass
today you came up with an equal blue key
Cindy a human encroachment rotating with
a nail create a current limiter are
available Nakata - Ichiko but
historically okay today hey guys this
was wires kpop support this time